[موسيقى]
هو ثاني أفضل شيء عندما
تقول كلبك إنني أفعل ما يفعله بعض أصحاب الكلاب ،
وهو جعل حيواناتهم الأليفة تشارك في حفل زفافهم وهم
يسيرون في الممر حاملين زهرة
تتظاهر لالتقاط الصور حتى أول
رقصات مع حيواناتهم الأليفة التي تقدم
خدمات رعاية الكلاب مثل
يوجد الآن حب الكفوف
الذي لا يفعل شيئًا سوى تحضير الحيوانات الأليفة
لحفلات الزفاف ، ولكن كيف تستعد
للعقيد في المختبر الأصفر ،
وصفت المدربة دانييل مارسياسو بأنها متحمسة ومفعمة بالحيوية
العقيد لم
يسير في الممر عندما تزوج أصحابه
في بورتسموث رود آيلاند
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
[ضحك]
يأتي العقيد وهو يجلد ما يدور
في رأسك
يا إلهي
فستان العروس تقول العروس كيت جينو إن العريس قام
بحماية الفستان بأي ثمن ووضع
نفسه بين عروسه وكلبهم
ولكن لا أحد يحمي  مايك
[ضحك]
لقد كان دائمًا أكبر لاعب في لعبة كرة القدم
ونحن سعداء جدًا لأن جميع
أصدقائنا وعائلتنا تمكنوا من رؤيتها على الهواء مباشرة
وفي أثناء العمل ، وهذا شيء
سيتذكره الجميع دائمًا  ص حقًا
تقول كيت إنها وزوجها الآن
رسموا
أنهما مهووسان بكلبهما وقرروا أنه لا توجد طريقة
للزواج دون وجوده هناك
ولكن عندما قفز العقيد على ثوبها
في منتصف الوعود في ذلك الوقت
كان ذلك  حيث قلنا أن
الكولونيل حان الوقت لتذهب
إليه برفقة مدربه ،
من المفترض أن تكون حفلات الزفاف التي قام بها المدرب في المكان الذي
وضعت فيه الخاتم ولكن في هذه الحالة
وصل العريس في سترته وسحب
منه جلدًا خامًا علاج جينيموس cnn
new york
[  موسيقى]